okay four people joining this livestream
this is a meeting about well from
language features I think we just
wrapped up version 12 so these these
features will be mostly going into
subsequent versions and let's get
started here so we we're talking about
random instance so this is trying to
normalize about the behavior of our
various random scar type functions um
okay
great all of those I know about they all
seem just fine so we have so I perhaps
subdivided a bit much but we have sort
of the things I call basic random and
then the specialized basic random which
are behaves essentially the same way but
they return things which are a bit more
interesting than just numbers so okay
random color random to your position
random variate by the way when it has a
learned distribution that came from the
from the machine learning system will
also return something less trivial right
I think random Verity is going to work
on learned distribution so give you a
random cat picture or something yeah
anyway okay so okay well so wait a
minute another example of randomness is
the random instance well I claim that
random instance doesn't fit in really
and you need to think about this so
right so then we have the things which
are clearly just using randomness so
that's things like it yeah I don't know
why that section is closed there but if
you if you look at things they if you
look at the things that used to
randomness right so that's things like
you know features based plot
doesn't well uses randomness except that
it's a fixed randomness right I mean it
doesn't the default is to use a fixed
random seed correct
sure again well but the point is that
they're using randomness for not for
randomness sake so it's like can we can
we just get to the cut to the chase here
what is the issue that there's a non
inconsistency between the way that
randomness is accessed in these
functions or what well the point is I
the point is I don't think random
instance is properly thought out okay so
we have we have right so we have so if
we look at the basic random things they
they don't take random seating options
and they return random things then we
have okay so so wait a minute these
things are externally seated so for
example if I were to do random random
this and I would say seed random one two
three four random image right and this
let's do it in a case where I can tell
what's going on a little bit more whoops
um try five just the list five hey sorry
the number five it's not what I want to
know I wanted I wanted a thing that
would give me a five by five array so
maybe I say five ten by ten okay so now
if I do that again I'll get the same
thing right
correct so these are externally seeded
rec right and these things don't have an
internal seating option is that correct
correct
okay and Wow okay so it's a little funky
because this is using weight no random
that takes no no it's just he'd ran them
yeah it's just taking seed random right
okay what is random geo position
so I don't know why it's showing up into
context there but its position that your
position takes a region and a number of
points
oh yeah right it's like random point but
explora okay but so why is it in red as
apparently you have another random geo
position in a different context for some
reason well that should be track down I
mean that's some it's not red in my yeah
okay mine how do you find out what what
what's in what the different context
version oh look it's names yeah it's in
prototypes backtick is that our notes
thing I have no idea I mean I know it
has a thing called something like that
okay
well that has to be tracked down um so
can somebody okay and it either is a
Roger issue or it's a or it's a bill
this year of some kind yeah but but but
for some reason it seems to still work
hi this is very very confusing okay so
if I say here oops so now does random
geo position also not have it's also
externally seated is that correct okay
so I mean one of the things you're going
to point out here is that all these
random functions have external seating
yep and not only do they have external
seating but they affect they affect
effectively affect the seed for
subsequent calls exactly yes okay all
right so control around in this block
random random seeding okay so random
seeding is localized to that function
correct all right
and so I mean one thing that I would
like to offer as a possibility right is
that all the random functions could take
a random seeding option which would be
essentially a shorthand for block R and
seed random and unblocked so to speak
and that that would be a convenient way
I mean you know if we're if we're
comparing the code of you know random
image blah blah blah you know five ten
ten I don't even know what the five
means what does that five mean um there
must be like the maximum value okay so
we have a choice between that and block
random of seed random a blah blah blah
semicolon this and I would argue that
that that that form is a nice you know
sort of functional type form although
that the the second form is more
powerful absolutely much more powerful
the first form is purely a shorthand
that would basically allow you it's it's
it's a shorthand for a localized random
seeding within this function okay so
let's keep going here well well I think
that the question whether we do that is
partly related to what I think your
complaint about random instances which I
agree is not consistent right now so
let's just let's okay so random entity
okay so feature space plots so one of
the points is things like fix your space
plot can't there randomness can never
leak out right and if you specify the
random seating value is that true with
random seating automatic it leaks out
I don't think so does it change the
state I don't does it yes it's not
obviously correct to do that to me
random seating automatic it would make
more sense well okay so here's an
argument random seating automatic could
do a reseeding from the randomness
source okay which could be different
which I believe is inherited
oh that's inherited okay I was gonna say
inherited would be take it from the take
it from the ambient random stream an
automatic would mean reseed I think
that's what it is it's what it says in
documentation of what I'm sitting okay
so it is exactly what I just said so we
just reinvented what what I thought it
should be automatic says automatically
reset every time okay great that's
exactly what I would have expected right
that should not leak out so this one use
externally seeded random numbers does
leak right no I don't think it should
Lee
how can a not leak it'll give the same
answer every time if you if you run the
same function three times with inherited
it will then give the same answer every
time I mean look at the basic example
I'm sitting goes to automatic and
clearly it's affected the random state
right those would have no no no it's
right you're wrong you're wrong
it's reseeding it's like doing a seed
random open/close each time okay and in
fact this should give an example and
let's do it so why are those two
different because it's reseeding
it's reseeding okay let me show you what
I think these are doing okay okay so
that's that okay so what I claim this is
doing is the equivalent in here of
saying block random okay of let me show
you block random of seed random
open/close which seeds from the entropy
source you see what I'm saying it
recedes every time so let's let's see
whether I'm right in my claim that if I
say inherited here okay so I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna try something which I
claim will work okay so let's say I say
random seed doesn't matter one something
okay whoops seed random rather
okay of that by the way it's not totally
obvious that returning null is the right
thing to do that but that's a different
issue um okay
find instance okay this this oh yeah see
that's intention all season that's how
we defined it okay it takes it it so it
it it so so whatever your randomness so
you could change that around I'm seeing
it would give a different value but it
just inherits it inherits a random state
from outside whatever that random state
from outside happens to be it always
localizes so random in always localizes
which is why your argument about putting
in these other functions there's a local
thing as a reasonable thing yeah okay
fair enough and if I now say here random
integer blah blah blah and then I do it
again I'll get a different answer
bingo okay that makes sense that's
pretty decent so what's the difference
between inherited and automatic Rob
inherited you can set with seed random
automatic there's no way you can set it
right automatic just complete basically
randomly selects a seed from the current
time and you know various other system
parameters um could we please add some
examples to scope okay okay all right so
let's keep going here okay okay
so random entity right so well before we
get to random entity because that's more
of an implementation thing so random
instance mm-hmm right so first of all we
have this very general thing very
general sounding thing which at the
moment understands exactly one head oh
yeah yeah we know that right but well
the question is so question a is you
know what other things do we see taking
this I mean just really feels more like
your your
you know what I was calling the
specialized basic randomness okay so I
think what we imagine is find instance
getting a I mean find instance already
takes a random seating option I
understand that and I thought with what
I heard about this meeting that random
instance was gonna be some specialized
version of fine instance well it's
Michael Hill ian is here at least he was
yeah I think Michael is the relevant one
if he could be found I mean he's the one
who had an opinion about what this
should do I just tried to find them
right but the point is I mean so so
right so Paul was very sure that the
default should be automatic rather than
one two three four for the random
seating option for random instance yes
and in fact that's the documented
default
I think that's weird which is problem
one problem two is what else do we think
can go inside of here yeah okay I
understand I understand I think that's
okay so this okay what is this this is
the thing see it's an
just in question right because I mean
these are things which are defined by
constraints what should go inside here
it's right so let me at the end so the
network context had some a random
instance function which I discovered
once I merged this anything needed to
resolve the conflict so what does that
do and is it more like this random
instance or is it more like the other
guys see I don't know oh you mean the
Neo Network framework you said yes no I
don't know what you're talking about
okay look I think we need to find
Michael because we we discussed a
variety of you know different cases of
this but but let's try and let's hear
about what the issue is random entity is
right so so you can see it's not
respecting block random that that should
give the same country ten times and the
way do we understand what the issue is I
think so
Jeremy can undoubtedly explain it better
than I can but I think it has to do with
at least part of random entity has to
run on the server and the server doesn't
know what the random state of the client
is so so we're gonna have to tell it
well it's more than that because it's
not all Wolfram language code on the
server and so there is no I mean that I
mean I'm life and I think right I think
we did do something so that it's seated
so that I think what ETA is saying is
obsolete AG information actually I think
it is actually possible to pass in the
ceiling and and get it to be
reproducible but it's not you know it's
not a one-to-one correspondence just
because of all those implementation
details right but you're saying I mean
although this is could be considered a
bug right now this is a fixable bug
when you're saying if I say block random
and I said around this for example if
we're gonna say block random I want to
say table yeah okay so it does the same
thing I returned that okay so that is a
bug basically right of unknown of
unknown complexity to fix in in random
entity yeah and and my recollection is
that we did add support for that on the
Alpha server and so maybe it just needs
to be hooked up to entity value okay
really an implementation detail it's
just I've made a complete list of it of
every random function I could find so
okay all right so let's boil this this
discussion down so first issue is it is
complaining about the generality of the
name find instance oh sorry random
instance and second point is there's the
possibility of adding random seed random
seating options to all of the random
functions I support that second thing I
think it's a nice consistent thing to do
and the default value for most functions
well what is the default value for most
functions the default value is Yetta
Yetta valley we don't have right now
which is neither automatic they neither
reseed see what I'm saying
right so that's sort of okay so it's
it's a beyond inherited I mean maybe
maybe what it should say is random
seeding arrow none that was my thought
that means it's a pass-through business
and do we see that's a good question I
would say yes if we can
reasonably easily hey I mean the way
that things should do it is just by
using block random yes well except we
need the opposite right to implement
none we need unblock random or something
right no it's a little it's a little
more complicated how to do that I mean
basically I don't think it's the world's
most important thing I don't think on
day one find instance we support random
seating just don't think anybody cares
okay um okay so that's look it's not the
most urgent thing but I think that's a
nice consistency thing to add okay so
let's come back to the question of
random instance and I just don't think
we can do that um without Michael so we
may have to put that off now obviously
that's a version twelve features so we
need to be mindful of it I have a say
you still here so perhaps random
instance should be the version of fine
distance with a different random sitting
value well yes it could be it could be
because since a geometric scene is like
a set of equations it's just a set of
equations for geometric objects but you
know we can be sorted as a set of
equations as we would feed to find this
sense right well so that that raises the
possibility that that instead of random
instance we call it find instance except
that and right now with find instance
that does well find these stunts could
always return the same thing because
fine distance has a definite random
sitting yeah but does it return the same
thing yeah yes and we can't change that
and if it happens to be able to give an
instance without invoking randomness and
the random state then the random seating
option is ignored but the default value
of the random seating is one two three
four so by default yeah I understand so
what Jose is saying is we could
introduce a random instance which in the
case of things like
this is uninterestingly different from
find instance but in the case of this
too so what's happened here is that
whereas here that variable is an
explicit find instance you know variable
here that's been implicitly put in this
geometric scene I'm making sense yes but
perhaps in the future
random instance there will have cases in
which it needs a second argument well I
agree I agree don't like I like Jose's
idea of just making this making this
fine instance and wait no he's not
saying that he's saying there should be
a random instance which is basically the
same as fine instance but has different
a random seating option right that's
what you're saying and then we can go
backwards and make find instance work on
the things that I think would be a
better ideas just don't don't have
random instance and call this find
instance and just it's another set of
things for which find instance works yes
I agree that that's not a crazy idea I
must have made I didn't know that find
instance was able to handle randomness
yeah I agree I agree which means that
that that we they're having too closely
allied functions find instance and
random instance seems not completely
silly to me right because most find
functions do not handle randomness if I
right now one thing it's a little crazy
weird right is look at this this
argument structure there's variables
domain and then the number of instances
[Music]
well so is it distinguishable from Vaz
it's a little bit of a hack but I mean
we could certainly have a two argument
form of random instance
you know what's funny here is this is
related to a bunch of things that roger
has of implicit functions which we could
imagine defining which has this ex is
essentially a localized variable so I'm
saying I mean so in other words we could
imagine a you know implicit function or
something I'm not sure implicit region
or it does that I'm just you know I'm
saying you know X an element of reals
so I'm saying if we had something like
that and then said find instance of that
see another thing that's very weird okay
what is fine instance of a geometric
scene returning it's another geometric
scene is that right yes I'm sorry what
or let's talk geometric scenes right
right but that's a different thing
than this thing here where we would be
saying you know we're essentially the
localized version of this will be
something totally weird that says that
for example mm-hmm well it depends how
you look at it because we could think
that if we have find instance of on a
set of equations but we return is
another set of equations for no it's not
right because equations would just be
satisfied for those X's what we're
trying to return is the instances
okay what's the analogy I see the system
you'll be returning the values of a b c
and o diptych points well but it inserts
them inside the geometric scene so
what's the analog of that for equations
C
what this is effectively saying is
there's two things that are going on
here one is the triangles into an
equation at all it's just a hello I'm
here right but some of these other
things are a certain mean that's not
really an equation although it's it is a
mixture of an equation and a thing
because it's a circle but it's a it has
it has the implicit constraint that ABC
all lie on a circle the triangle also is
like that because the solver will try to
find a non degenerate triangle right so
circle through is sort of like the
equation a o squared equals bo squared
equals zero squared sure but I'm trying
to understand that there's in addition
to the equations which just assert true
or false
geometric scene has an additional
character right which is that it
actually represents the scene great and
I'm asking what's the a log of that in
the case of the food that fine instance
usually gets fed it would be something
like equation object which contains the
equation comma X goes to 3 2 was 2 is
the equation and the solution to the
equation right yeah okay but when this
gets its solution you know right well it
takes the right look at the input form
of that yeah it basically puts in
replacement rules just like solve might
you know what the heck is this see of
geometric quantity what is that it
introduced additional parameters for the
center and radius of the circle through
well what is that thing alright so I
guess it's saying that the radius of the
circle is one point four seven seven and
[Music]
why is it making that second thing a
hold form thing yes that's a well there
there's an existing issue of you know
certain things that are Auto evaluating
that and you know they stick we're
sticking into hold form until the
geometry team makes them not ought to
evaluate okay okay so listen again we
need Michael but I think the way we're
going to go with this is we're gonna
have a fine instance random instance
pair that we're gonna support generally
and random instance is going to be
happily used for this particular case of
geometric scene at this time anybody
violently object to this approach and
and I think also there is a
machine-learning use case I mean I'm
trying to think I mean again I'm still
trying to understand the nature of this
thing which is a combination of a thing
and constraints on the thing I do
you know it will be more like saying um
you know constraints constraints on ABXY
you know x squared plus y squared equals
1 for example that will be the analog
here and then when we say random
instance of that of that thing then it
would become and this is a rot a Rob
type issue because this is also
constraints X arrow 1 you know why arrow
1 whatever it is x squared plus y
squared equals 1 that's the direct
analog of the geometric seen case now is
that useful I think it's completely
useless I mean what's a look I'm joking
dead at least a 1 of X or Y had better
be 0 if we wanted to okay fine yes I'm
just wrong okay example imagine that
random instance took the geometric is
since as it is right now and then a list
of four names which are the new names of
your points and then in that case it
returns capital a goes to 1 comma 2 and
capital B goes to Sigma 2 I see what
you're saying i suture sign so in other
words if if what we did here was to say
it's a little weird cuz I mean that then
that what you're saying is saying find
instance of this comma oh I see I see so
we couldn't principle to say ABC for
example here not even recording all of
the points right so that information you
are interested in right provides and
then that would give you just like find
instance does you know it gives you the
values right that seems pretty
reasonable
whereas random instance in the default
case
yeah I mean random instance in the
default case would just give you four
for an equation we just give you true
again I think this needs Michael and
maybe also add them yes extending find
instance we probably want to add them
around yes okay um okay alright uh okay
so I think we have a path let's talk
about its distance matrix right
so it's distance matrix on a TN
production yes and it has some so if
maybe if you look at iliyan and my
examples it has a couple of examples
where actually I thought I knew what I
was doing but when I looked at it again
today I'm not even sure what it's doing
so maybe a TN can explain and yeah so I
think the basic problem is I mean yeah
so interpretation of the data it's used
I mean it has been implemented with the
same interpretation of data as all the
other machine learning functions which
don't know symbolic data
it's numeric nominal you know image
whatever or whatever and some people
expect distance matrix to interpret
things differently I guess this as
matrices kind of adds the frontier
between machine learning functions and
more olive oil numeric actually not why
is it different from norm and he isn't
norm another thing like distance matrix
well no
gives you the norm of a single thing and
distance matrix is giving you the
pairwise distances I know I know I know
I know but I'll just mention that it's
very unfortunate that Norma valuates for
symbolic stuff I have a thing the three
type sorry sorry no no go ahead okay
well like I can you know in the
optimization modeling a common case it
comes up there's something like norm of
a dot X minus B or B as a vector and
when norm evaluates it it threads in
correctly and that's that's completely
and we cover a ball okay so what are we
gonna do about that well we we've come
up with a few few workarounds all right
isn't it or am i confused so my argument
I mean maybe maybe it's too late cuz
distance matrix is now for a while
wouldn't it be nice if distance matrix
just didn't evaluate when it had
symbolic increase I don't think that's
correct necessarily I mean listen listen
you're telling me that you want a
version of normal way we got puncher
with like a noise here um you're telling
me that
I mean okay that that ship has sailed so
let's probably but but let's look at
this output am I correct that distance
matrix is this right so well in some
cases right so if you and one and nine
for your two for X&Y there right then
you'll get the the the end of one and
aliens email at least I hope you you
will beautiful but if you as you can see
okay so if I put in here one an X it
will interpret things as being no me
know with distance matrix what you're
saying if I say distance matrix yeah
these would have a different result its
use the same that interpretation as but
it isn't that people expect that the
default distance function is always so
clearly on distance and it's not this is
crazy
this result is crazy thing we just got
out here is crazy in my view better
Steven as it's doing the distance
between the vector 1 X and the vectors 1
9 no it's just interpreted that as
nominal so 1 X and 9 3 different stuff
and he's using Hamming distance I think
in that case okay so it's just wrong if
I might say so I mean in the case of
symbolic variables there I don't even
know I mean what are you telling me that
if I look at distance matrix of
something like you know ABB AAA it's
good to kind of auto select to use yes
yes
it won't use a Canadian distance in that
case so very we
distance whatever it is it's probably at
a distance no it's a list right right
you're giving it matrices you probably
should give it just if you just get
conjectures it would be a bit less
confusing right so this is presumably
that's right maybe maybe the heuristic
should be that if anything is symbolic
we assume it's it's complex which is
what we do throughout the rest of the
kernel yeah and we actually give okay
I'm confused while I'm doing it so this
is so the correct thing would be
distance matrix of 1x right right that's
crazy in my opinion in my opinion that
the output from that should be is this
right interprets these as being
numerical but just X being the way
sushma can you please report the fact
that this insertion I beam thing is
still not fixed
yeah okay I claim the result should be
this do you agree with me try try to
have the option distance function goes
to a clearing distance what's a little
weird what does that mean I guess it's
Euclidean distances and you think it
takes a abs by default yeah I mean I'm
sure that it's taking the ABS because
it's not seeing a positive number there
but I'm not sure why the Euclidean
distances and evaluate me want to pee
what numbers is boot evaluator so it's
just they're not all weighted but at
least this is something numeric between
vectors yeah that's why
right so what on earth is this this is
this is somehow threaded you could even
distance down to the individual elements
rather than using it as a vector
distance because you specified a Killian
distance though it will use whatever you
put there but you can say clear on
distance of one and three and it will
give you two so that's weird that's not
what that's not as advertised here but
what is cos norm works on numbers as
well okay but I agree when there's a
bunch of numeric value and just X I mean
in symbolic stuff it should interpret
things of being numeric and it's just an
unknown thing you have to interpret an
unknown axis but if you have symbolics
and numbers I think treating it
numerically is probably the right way to
go okay so that's it let's zoom out for
a second what the issues are okay first
question is what distance matrix should
do with symbolic input second thing is
the concern the complaint from Rob that
norm he wants a norm that doesn't
evaluate right yes
however there it's very useful to have
the existing norm so so there's a
question of can we come up with a named
object that is the unev al you ating
norm i came up at one point in our in
our stuff of something that called
vector norm why is that gonna help
anything because that's because but I
see because then then vector norm means
that the things in it are supposed to be
vectors is that right right it always
interprets them in this vector space
sinks so it's always the it's always a
Frobenius type norm and it never does a
matrix norm and it also just doesn't
evaluate unless their numerical vectors
okay but I mean does the name back to
Norman apply that it's not gonna value
it except for vectors not obviously no
right you're thinking of some sort of n
norm
so his vector no norm for you know lists
XY no I understand that point I'm trying
to understand whether the name back to
norm connotes that in a useful way
we sort of did that with the vector the
that with a vector inequalities that if
any of the parts are symbolic they no
but that's but that's because they are
vector inequalities that work
differently
I mean vector less it's fundamentally a
different kind of thing yes it is
different another list in there so I
have to have this yes
by the way Rob you've got some
background noise that's driving me crazy
at least okay well I don't quite
understand you know the logic behind a
vector norm that doesn't evaluate that
seems like a separate issue seems like
what we're dealing with here it's just a
simple bug in distance matrix that when
it has a symbolic variable in it it
shouldn't be doing you know it should be
doing that in treating it symbolically
now the question obviously for Etienne
is you know are there other machine
learning functions which have that same
issue
I don't think it's an issue for all the
machine learning function like when you
use classify should you treat like let's
say you take what you put in this matrix
and you put in to classify
yes right with some with some labels yes
should we treat excess missing and no
yeah no so I agree so it should treat as
a I mean I mean that's two K there's two
possibilities either understands the
data as the in American X is just a
missing numeric value the data as
nominal which does yes right what it
should do yeah so I think it's it's not
a problem for other machine learning
functions what about things like nearest
what do they do
pigtail just complain right yes its
complaint yeah excuse me didn't complain
well no it'll only complain when it
actually realizes because you might have
a distance function as a special
definition for X it complains when you
tried it documentation you replace one
value by evaluating sorry do you think
it's correct that the sniff gives no
error at this stage yes I think I think
I think that has to be cracked um okay
okay all right so conclusion is a TN
should look at how to fix distance
matrix so that it won't may have that
problem okay and meanwhile Rob is going
to come up with some idea about vector
norm possibly make service I think
make this ship this past I think we
found we found some other ways around it
I mean because there's you know there's
a whole I mean the the big the big
problems for modeling and the
optimization stuff for norm plus and
times you know and we basically found
ways to work around those it seemed to
be you know reasonably not not too
complicated okay all right fine one
thing I should add for this metric
business is how far do we go so if it's
just a symbol there's no definition it's
going to pretty easy to okay pretty
clear what what what I should do but
let's say it's an image let's say you
have some numeric value and then you
have an image in the middle
I think there are certain raw types
which will gradually expand that we
natively support
what means like if it's not X but f of X
let's say it's still interpreted as
being a symbol search for further things
being affirmative lay of a type what do
you mean so you know check is it a
string is it an image is it a number
except cetera said right otherwise it's
symbolic otherwise it's a symbolic
variable right the fall-through case is
it's symbolic that's fair right which I
think you know if it falls through and
it does something crazy in most cases if
it actually falls through they probably
are doing something symbolic and they'll
get what they want
I agree yep okay let's go on to the next
item right so so you've cheated because
I was going to ask you the question to
tell me which of these four is an
inactive operator how did you make the
second one by gray by explicitly having
a great format for it no but the second
one is not to here is that some kind of
bitmap or something no I don't know try
try resizing the input cell you created
I think maybe was just pasted in as a
textile rather than as an input cell is
my guess okay oh okay so we got a
variety of colors here so how did you
get that gray one that's Auto times
isn't it
that is Auto times okay right and so you
know you expressed a desire for using
the cross for inactives of x which is a
pretty easy thing to do and and and we
can do that but I wanted to bring up
it's my main hesitation the reason I
didn't just do it when you said you
wanted it is because well is this what's
the issue well just that it's you know
visually ambiguous like that you can
tell could you have told me what
one was the inactive one if I thought
about it yeah I probably could have told
you it was this one okay
what what wait what is this one how did
you make that one what is that that is
the traditional form inactive one so
traditional form is always yeah black
blocks itself up yeah and and always
ambiguous so I mean so what was I asking
for and what was the concern you right
so what this actually does I mean so
this is just a mock-up if you have value
if you now do percent forty seven and
they let it evaluate you'll see what the
current formatting is well that's all
for and you know I I guess I don't have
a problem with changing the traditional
form one my main canal is that the
standard form one like I said it could
be confused with Auto times okay but but
that's why it's brownish okay am I am I
the only worry worth working in in this
call I think it's a reasonable issue to
raise but I think we're okay okay and I
assume that is times the only case where
we have a I mean you know I would say
that um well power we have to use carrot
because we don't have yeah a way to put
anything an indication of of in
activeness exactly yeah so plus is fine
power we have to use the carrot that's
otherwise we have nothing to draw and I
think I'm sure there are various is that
right what do we think about that it's
not obviously right to me
[Music]
that would be more work to fix it's not
seems desirable to me to fix that very
desirable sure I think this is a common
thing people wonder what to do to have
essentially a night of formulas to think
about that case cases with the x case
it's just substituting to character this
case will require actual thought about
how to make this happen
so that this will probably not be 412
the x thing is like I said great
excellent we can get into a comment from
Ethan on a live stream recommending
adding an MS Lib as a method for nearest
currently it doesn't scale well for
large indices with custom distance
functions and then I have never heard of
an MS live so Rob there's a drug drop
out Rob story I'm here but I've never
heard of that library why don't you look
it up that's some figure out what's
going on thank you to Ethan for
suggesting this all right last item here
sub values and format values boy sub
values you know they've been around for
30 years we've never documented them
right so yeah so you'd need to go to
docq tools to actually see it right we
have internal pages which as I say right
there it's not like these that we can
just release them but it's it's becoming
a bit more obvious since we're now sort
of because of the new information
they're becoming sort of more visible
right so you know at least the names are
becoming more visible I think we should
just bite the bullet we've been using
these names for 30 years and we seem to
know what they mean and I think we
should just you know just have them
become real okay
I mean it doesn't not 4:12 it requires a
little bit more thought
but I think that that's what we should
go do okay format values let's take a
look at that it's okay
I wonder when we created these pages I
bet these pages are 20 years old I'm
sure they are accident my guess is like
well actually my guess is probably
they're 15 years old right I think these
were probably created when the book was
being oh yeah just my mother two
notebooks go okay all right well it's
late so I okay both sounds good thanks
to folks on the livestream thank you all
here see you later